[Music]
kevin gausman the veteran right-hander
making his 23rd start of the year 10-5
on the year with a 2-3-1 era he has been
fantastic 157 strikeouts with a 2-3-1
era josh van meter leads off
he got it with a real good splitter
there for his first strikeout of the
night and that is as nasty as it can be
and that's exactly what we saw in this
last outing splitter with a two-seam
movement an absolute perfect location
just fading away from van meter two and
two demarte top of the first just
underway
and he got it with the splitter strike
three that is as good as he's got right
there he's had two kill splitters here
both strike threes
and there's that quickness at the end it
he's
martay is convinced it's a fastball out
of his hand and then when he commits
himself to it it just dies very
encouraging beginning for kevin gausman
one two
got him with the fastball right on the
outside three straight strikeouts to
start his night for kevin gausman harold
kelly on the mound for the diamondbacks
outstanding against these giants last
week eight scoreless innocent boy over
his last nine starts the diamondbacks
have won six of those nine merrell is
five and one with an era of 2.44
now chris bryant
weighed on the move with the pitch
bryant got a fast ball and got under it
haven smith fighting that wind and it
drops in behind him wade's got to get to
second they got to play on there and
they get the out so it worked out for
the diamondbacks but we talked earlier
cool and breezy in san francisco that
wind right now seems to be blowing in
from right field wade was running with
the pitch all the way to second base
and now he has to get back to first base
when he thinks pavement's going to make
the play and now he's forced out at
second base that'll go as a fielder's
choice for chris bryant now brandon
crawford comes up chance for the giants
to do some damage here never got a run
across against merrell kelly in eight
innings last week
crawford pulls that one down the right
field line that's a base hit that's
going to score chris bryant
posey on his way to third he'll get the
stop sign there as the ball is finally
dug out in the corner brandon crawford
with the double
it's one nothing giants
he gets up a minute score position two
outs and this is not a hanger either
that's that cutter on the inside corner
and he just digs it out that's
an exceptional job of hitting a tough
pitch and a two out rbi double by
brandon crawford to give the giants the
lead here's the two one to it from
guzman with a man on ground ball left
side that's fair just fair third base
line on the third goes calhoun and the
dive back's in business here and calhoun
looks like he's heard of third base he's
down made the turn oh he's he's limping
is that another hammy
off the field that's too bad so ellis is
heading to third base second and third
no outs for peralta
it's the tapper just past the bound
crawford has one play and the
diamondbacks get the equalizers ellis
we're tied to one nobody out in the
second inning this would be the 45th
pitch for merrell kelly giants already
have more hits against him than they did
in eight innings last week up the middle
into center field
that's a hit for kevin gausman the
ostremski scores
two to one giants
so he took the the sign from
ron woodis the hit side knocking her run
sign and he makes it pay off and i'm
just kidding there's no such sign here
it is a two seam challenge right at the
belt just trying to put it in play and
lo and behold it finds the outfield
jastremski's lead-off walk has turned
into a run already lamont wave junior at
the top of the lineup now can start to
think big inning against merrell kelly
wayne at the plate left hand about he
swings it down to first out at first and
they get floors at the plate boy that
helps that goes as a 3-2 double play and
then sob number two in the only two outs
out 3-2 pitch coming up to bryant
here it is
struck him out swinging so the giants
out of all of that get only one run they
do so with two hits in the ending and
they'll strand a runner in scoring
position buster posey single to center
in the first inning right-hander against
right-hander kelly to the plate
buster hits a high drive into deep right
field way back there and goodbye
over the willie mays wall up onto the
arcade 3-1 giants an opposite field home
run for buster posey
well that was a two-seamer that ended up
out over the heart of the plate
and buster
just hammered it jumped off his bat at
102 miles an hour
15th of the year three to one giants
101 rough
[Applause]
backhand play nick ahmed can't quite
turn two but that was a pirouette down
there
at second base on the feed from van
meter
not many short stops will make this play
this is something else
wow
and nowhere else to go with this ball
van meter shovels it back to nick who
bare hands it steps on the pace with his
right foot and throws all in one motion
not enough to get darren rough at first
base but what an athletic play now
farcia will try and do some damage with
two on one out time runs are on base
sir of the fastball up and varsio
drilled it into center
haven smith coming home
peralta's in at third and it's three to
two
gaussman didn't get that one up quite
enough not where buster wanted it and
this time dalton didn't miss it nice
controlled swing that time from dalton
varshall really lets his hands
control the action that time not as much
body involved and smokes a line drive
into center field yeah that is the word
that was well struck three to two giants
in the fourth inning wade junior now
with a runner at first and only one out
deep center field
martay
still going back
off his glove into the ball pin goodbye
a two run homer
five to two giants
boy has this game changed
in a short period of time and watch the
break the giants catch here
martay goes up
and he hits that ball and he's thinking
i've got this one
just off the tip of his little finger on
the glove and lamont wave junior hits
number 14 a two runner martial's gonna
think about that for a while
chris bryant now brian singled his last
time up one through three
five and four in era just under three
and a half brian hits it a mile up in
the air
cattell marte is there
and faria escapes trouble in the sixth
inning stains five to san francisco
giants lead five to two judah nobody on
the one-one pitch
that one to center field martay back
martay watches it go
brandon crawford
up over that left center field wall
his 19th of the year and career home run
number
125 for brandon
oh well and
he does it against the guy that came out
of the same high school
[Music]
that's some falcon on falcon crime 106
miles per hour going
over the wall alex dickerson will hit
here in the eighth inning
dickerson high drive right field it is
gone and out into san francisco bay
and he gets his chant to seamer that
goes right out over the middle of the
plate
is exactly what he was looking for
and for the 90th time a giants hitter
has hit one into mccubby cove
seven to two giants
tell marte
trying to keep this game going for the
diamondbacks
fastball strike three called and that's
exactly how garcia and the giants end it
7-2 the final 14 hits tonight lamont
wade brandon crawford buster posey alex
dickerson all go deep and a nice
all-around giants win
[Applause]
you